Neuronové sítě jsou výkonná třída algoritmů strojového učení
a existují v mnoha variantách
neexistuje způsob, jak neuronové sítě náležitě probrat
v úvodním videu
jako je tohle, takže tady jen identifikujeme pár klíčových komponent
neuronové sítě a celkový pracovní postup
abychom pochopili, jak může kvantové počítání přispět
neuronová síť je propojený graf neuronů
neuron je v podstatě jen věc, která uchovává číslo
a to číslo se často nazývá aktivace – jak moc
je neuron zapnutý nebo vypnutý
neurony jsou seřazeny do vrstev
první vrstva je vstupní vrstva
a poslední je výstupní vrstva
mezi nimi jsou vrstvy používané ke zpracování, které se nazývají
skryté vrstvy. Aktivace
vstupní vrstvy se načítá přímo z dat, která se mají analyzovat
jako je třeba stínování pixelů v obrázku
aktivace neuronů v následující skryté vrstvě jsou určeny
neurony ve vstupní vrstvě
a váhami znázorněnými čarami spojujícími všechny neurony
ve vstupní vrstvě se všemi neurony v
následující vrstvě – jinými slovy aktivaci určíme
neuronu ve skryté vrstvě
jako vážený součet všech
vstupních aktivací. Můžeme
také přidat bias – posun
možná chceme aktivovat neuron
ve skryté vrstvě ne tehdy, když je vážený součet jen
kladný, ale až tehdy, když překročí velkou prahovou hodnotu
pak často aplikujeme složitou funkci, abychom získali aktivaci
mezi nulou a jedničkou, jako je hyperbolický tangens
nebo někdy jinak –
rektifikovaná lineární jednotka. O tyto věci se
teď moc nemusíš starat. Jediná
důležitá věc, kterou si u těchto funkcí zapamatovat, je
že jsou nelineární
takže síť jako celek obsahuje jak lineární
tak nelineární komponenty
tentýž vážený součet aktivací, tentokrát
začínající aktivacemi
první skryté vrstvy a novými váhami
se rozšiřuje až do další skryté vrstvy
toto pokračuje až do poslední vrstvy, která je výstupní
výstupní vrstva má neurony odpovídající
kategoriím a aktivace nám říkají
jak moc si síť je jistá klasifikací
takže výstupní kategorie při analýze obrázků mohou být
pes, kočka, křeček a tak dále
a aktivace 0,95 na
neuronu pro psa by znamenala vysoký stupeň jistoty, že
obrázek znázorňuje psa. Svoji neuronovou síť můžeš začít
s náhodnou sadou vah
a biasů nebo ze známé rozumné počáteční konfigurace
ale pak je myšlenka taková, že zkontrolujeme
jak dobře neuronová síť věci klasifikuje
a vylepšíme ji. Používáme nákladovou funkci k popisu
toho, jak se naše neuronová síť odchyluje od
správné klasifikace. To zahrnuje výpočet
rozdílu mezi skutečnou hodnotou obrázku
– řekněme například hodnota jedna na neuronu
pro psa a nula na všech ostatních výstupních neuronech
a předpovězenými hodnotami
sečteme přes všechny kategorie
takže sledujeme nejen to, zda byla správná kategorie
nejvíce aktivována, ale také
jestli jsou nesprávné aktivace snižovány
sečteme přes všechny příklady v trénovací sadě
a získáme náklady. Poté
měníme parametry jako váhy v každé vrstvě
mezi všemi neurony a biasy na všech neuronech
k prohledávání se používají klasické optimalizační rutiny
pro nalezení lokálního minima v nákladové funkci
pokud se nic neudělá pro snížení složitosti tohoto
můžeš si představit, jaký
astronomický parametrický prostor jsme tady vytvořili
uvažujme neuronovou síť navrženou k analýze obrázků s
pouhými tisícem pixelů. Tato neuronová síť by mohla mít tisíc
vstupních neuronů, jen jednu jedinou skrytou vrstvu
a binární výstup jako kočka nebo pes
to je ten úplně nejjednodušší případ
a přesto odpovídá tisíci krát tisíci
čili milionu vah mezi vstupní a skrytou vrstvou
a dalším dvěma tisícům mezi
skrytou a výstupní vrstvou
možná také tisíci nebo
tak biasy. Takže tato jednoduchá neuronová síť by odpovídala
výrazně více než milionu parametrů. Ale buďme féroví –
moderní algoritmy obvykle zjednodušení dělají
v klasických neuronových sítích
a existují celé obory věnované tomu, aby tato minimalizace
byla možná a dokonce efektivní
ale faktem zůstává, že jde o velmi
vysoce dimenzionální problém
a trénování neuronové sítě
může být velmi časově náročné
a nákladné. Kvantová neuronová síť neboli QNN
funguje tak, že nejprve načte vstupní data
a pak aplikuje quantum circuits
odpovídající váhám mezi vrstvami
a nakonec vrstvu měření
pár klíčových bodů k tomu: načítání dat
a vážení jsou lineární operace
ale měření jsou nelineární
takže stejně jako v klasických neuronových sítích máme
jak lineární, tak nelineární komponenty
také váhové circuits
stále mají variační parametry
takže stále je třeba provést klasickou minimalizaci
tohle samozřejmě jen povrchně nastínilo kvantové neuronové
sítě, ale doufáme, že se budeš dál učit o aplikacích
kvantových neuronových sítí
a dalších aplikacích kvantového strojového učení
s IBM Quantum